اجراء قرابه ثلاثمائه من الجاليه المغربيه
المقيمه في السودان عبر رحلتين للطيران
المغربي انطلاقا من مطار بورت سودان فيما
عشرات اخرون من المغاربه جاري النقلهم من
الخرطوم برا الى بورتسودان الى المغرب عبر
رحلات جويه
اليوم الاول كان صعب بزاف لان الصراحه
الضرب كان حدانا ولكن الحمد لله من بعد
مشينا البلاصه امنه
لنا كيفاش نوصلوا
الاسبوع الاول من الحرف الخرطوم كانت
اجواء مرعبه جدا كان يعني اطلاق الرصاص
دوري انفجارات قويه طائرات يعني كانت
الاجواء شويه صعبه جدا بموجب قانون الاسره
في المغرب تمنح الام المغربيه الجنسيه
المغربيه لابنها من زوج غير مغربي ما سهل
اجلاء ابناء المغربيات المتزوجات من
سودانيين الى جانب عمال ومستثمرين مغاربه
في السودان
لحظه صعبه عمر حنا اصلا عمرنا ما عشناها
الله يحفظ لنا بلادنا والله يخلي لنا
سيدنا الصراحه كانت اسوء شيء اللي عديت
انا في حياتي كامله كانت شي حاجه اللي
خايبه بزاف كتسمعنك الصواريخ وتسمع شي طلق
الرصاص حداك تقول شويه وتموت كانت صعيبه
الطريق صعيبه مقداش عندهم وكانت مسافه
ديال 26 ساعه تشير تقديرات الى ان حوالي
الفي مغربي ومغربيه يعيشون في السودان
اكثر من نصف المغربيات متزوجات من
سودانيين في انتظار ما سيصل المصالح
الدبلوماسيه المغربيه في السودان من طلبات
الاجلاء من المغاربه غير المسجلين سابقا
في سفاره الرباط هنا نسوه مغربيات عدنا
الى المغرب عبر جسر الاجلاء الجوي احضرنا
نصف قلوبهن اي اطفالهن فيما تركنا نصف
القلب الثاني ازواجهم السودانيين
في العاصمه الخرطوم عادل الزبيري العربيه
من مطار محمد الخامس من مدينه الدار
البيضاء المغربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات